[Musique]
s'il n'est peut être pas le roi le plus
célèbre du xiiie siècle saint louis on
est le plus célèbre des saints
le xiiie siècle marque l'avènement d'
état moderne en même temps que c'est
face le monde issu de la féodalité
saint-louis incarne cette transition
avec toutes ses contradictions et
notamment l'attachement à un idéal celui
de la croisade louis 9 connu sous le nom
de saint louis va régner pendant 44 ans
de 1226 5270 et c'est véritablement
pendant ces quarante quatre années la
période de l'instauration solidement du
pouvoir royal
faut pas le le peindre comme quelqu'un
d'excessivement bon juste en toutes
circonstances et en tous lieux
c'était un homme de pouvoir c'était
aussi un homme certes très vertueux sa
canonisation a été justifiée mais il
était aussi un administrateur sévère
[Musique]
à la fin du xième siècle la première
croisade avait vu la création d'un
royaume latin en orient autour de
jérusalem après la conquête de la ville
sainte par godefroy de bouillon
l'organisation c'est quelque chose de
très important
c'est très structuré une croisade
d'abord il faut l'autorisation du pape
et c'est même où parfois une croisade
est organisée à l'initiative du pape
c'était aussi un acte militaire qu'un
acte de pèlerinage c'est à dire qu'il
est à la fois des soldats et des
pèlerins tandis qu'au cours de la
troisième croisade richard coeur de lion
réussi à sauver ce royaume des griffes
du grand chef de guerre musulman saladin
il ne put sauver jérusalem les croisades
suivantes n'ont guère modifier cette
situation déjà complexe au proche orient
mais elles ont permis la création d'un
autre état latin par des seigneurs
francs au détriment de l' empire
byzantin qui voit constantinople chute
hier une première fois la france de
saint louis est le pays le plus peuplé
de la chrétienté 10 millions d'habitants
sur les 60 que contre l europe 10
millions de paysans ou presque
la ville devient de plus en plus
attractive la population de paris est
estimé à cent mille habitants au début
du règne peut-être 150 milles à la mort
du roi
des chiffres qu'il faut tout de suite
relativisé avec ce qui caractérise
l'hégémonie de la puissance mongol au
xiiie siècle
sur l'ensemble du continent eurasiatique
gengis khan et ses descendants vont
construire par les armes le plus vaste
empire ayant jamais existé
33 millions de kilomètres carrés les
superficies cumuler la russie du canada
et des états unis
[Musique]
et
la géographie se transforme donc pour
les hommes du xiiie siècle
suscitant de vives inquiétudes dans le
monde chrétien ce dont a besoin ce
peuple c'est d'une réponse apportée par
un roi en qui on aurait entièrement
confiance
saint louis est né en 12 114 l'année de
bouvines bataille qui marque la victoire
de son grand père philippe auguste face
à l'empereur allemand du saint empire
germanique au thon quatre alliés du roi
d'angleterre jean sans terre une
coalition des deux autres nations
chrétiennes influente d'europe
occidentale bovine à sur l'hégémonie
capétienne en france et en occident
bouvines s'est déroulé un dimanche la
victoire consacre un protégé un
protecteur de dieu
philippe auguste sur les ennemis de dieu
jean sans terre et othon quatre qui ont
été excommuniés
l'empereur a subi une véritable punition
divine pour avoir osé attaquer un
dimanche un jour de trêve pour dieu
cette bataille marquera les esprits des
hommes du xiiie siècle et en particulier
celui de louis petit fils de philippe
auguste la france à partir de ce moment
là le royaume de france a repris
vraiment toute son importance
jean sans terre est priée de réguler de
repartir chez lui en angleterre on
récupère la touraine la normandie etc
etc et fait défaut lui avoir laissé à
son fils loïc 8 un royaume
brillant dans la tradition capétienne le
fils aîné porte le prénom du grand père
louis n'était donc pas l'aîné mais on
faire philippe meurt à l'âge de 9 ans en
12 118 en 12126 trois ans seulement
après la mort de la gueule louis devient
donc louis 9
succédant à un père dont le règne aura
été bref en raison d'une croisade à
l'intérieur du royaume de france celle
contre les albigeois
sous cette appellation on désignait des
hérétiques
en rupture avec l'église officielle
principalement les cathares ceux ci
reprochait notamment aux institutions
chrétiennes leur richesse ostentatoire
la très dure croisade contre les
albigeois a marqué les esprits jusqu'à
notre époque aussi c'est aussi beaucoup
de choses se sont mêlées il y avait des
rivalités entre seigneurs du du sud des
signes seigneur du nord derrière cette
hérésie
on retrouve ça après peu plus tard au
moment des guerres de religion
vainqueur sans savoir toutefois
éradiquer définitivement l'hérésie 8
rentrant à paris
épris de dysenterie et succombe en
laissant des consignes louis qui n'est
pas encore majeur lui succédera mais
sera sous la tutelle de sa mère
celle ci va ainsi participer à
l'histoire de france
bien plus que son défunt époux jean
blanche de castille est une dame une
mère comment dirais-je très possessive
et puis bigote aussi d'ailleurs inculque
à saint-louis la notion de dieu en
permanence dans sa vie elle construit
les abeilles
royaumont c est l le surveille
elle est vraiment derrière son dos à
chaque instant que dieu fait elle ne lui
laisse que très peu de liberté c'est une
mère possessive blanche de castille à 12
ans son fils louis et donc adoubés
chevaliers à soissons et sacré à reims
blanche de castille va alors saisir le
pouvoir face à l'insoumission des grands
seigneurs du royaume qui refusait d'être
gouverné par un enfant et par une femme
qui plus est étrangère
dans un premier temps elle négocie en
diplomate avisé au jeu des alliances
dans un système encore féodal
de plus le jeune louis à l'appui du
peuple une conscience populaire née de
bouvines est en train de se cristalliser
autour du roi institutions sacrées
saint-louis saura s'en souvenir
sa personnalité se distingue et on voit
qu'il est dans la continuité de philippe
auguste pour ce qui est de la suprématie
royal c'est à dire que partir de
philippe auguste on n'y a pas d'autres
familles aristocratiques qui peuvent
disque disputer la couronne de france
même si ça arrivera
il aura toujours un moment mais surtout
il ya l'idéal monarchique est très
implanté
blanche imposera son autorité notamment
lorsqu'il faut finalement prendre les
armes dans un second temps et mater la
révolte des bars où tant et si bien que
son fils devenu majeur en 12 134
continue à gouverner avec elle et cela
en parfaite harmonie
l'héritage de philippe auguste est entre
de bonnes mains d'une façon de plus en
plus insistantes le pouvoir monarchique
capétiens promulguer des lois qui
s'appliquent à l'ensemble d'un
territoire dont les frontières ressemble
de plus en plus à la france actuelle cet
héritage et même consolider lorsqu'en 12
134 louis prend pour épouse marguerite
de provence c'est la rencontre entre la
france du nord et la future france du
midi fait d'une femme charmante bien sûr
et très pieuse il fallait être pieux
parce que l'église riez à tous qui va
amener l'héritage de la provence
évidemment à la couronne et marguerite
de provence va être une reine et une
épouse absolument adorable elle fera je
crois 12 enfants à saint louis qui est
devenu saint mais qui n'avaient donc pas
fait voeu de chasteté 12 enfants dont le
dixième faut le savoir robert de bourbon
qui sera le l'ancêtre des bourban qui
vont régner depuis henri iv jusqu'à
louis xviii jusqu'à charles dix semaines
tandis que marguerite devient la jeune
reine blanche de castille reste reine de
france
louée à le sens dynastique il est le
premier roi de france à avoir connu son
grand-père de l'esprit de son aïeul
louer a hérité de celui de chef d'état
philippe auguste venait de faire prendre
à la monarchie française
le virage le plus important de toute son
histoire une centralisation
administrative financière et morale
autour de paris l'importance d'une ville
se mesure à l'aune de ses remparts la
forteresse du louvre conçu sous philippe
auguste témoigne du prestige politique
et économique de paris le louvre le
palais du louvre qui est d'abord une
forteresse médiévale et bien est bleu il
a été construit là en bord de seine peau
précisément surveiller l'accès côté
ouest de paris
et puis aussi pour que l'on marque parce
que il y avait déjà dans la cité le
palais royal
mais là il faut marquer l'importance
l'influencent de la monarchie avec ce
bâtiment merveilleux qu'était le louvre
tout l'occident chrétien connaît un
essor économique depuis le 11e siècle
ce dynamisme commence à bénéficier aux
grandes villes où transitent et se
monnaient une quantité toujours plus
grande de marchandises
louis 9 sait s'appuyer sur cette
vitalité pour consolider l'héritage du
patriarche et se faire respecter en tant
que chef d'état paris devenant ainsi une
capitale bien au delà du domaine du cap
essien mais un état doit pouvoir
s'appuyer sur des valeurs encore plus
solide
or une terrible nouvelle de
constantinople arrive aux oreilles de
louis 9 on l'apprend un beau jour de 237
que la couronne des pink à saintes le
roi des rois le jour de la passion est
prête à être vendue au plus offrant par
l' empire latins d'orient
acculé par des dépenses militaires
énorme afin de répondre aux assauts
répétés des grecs les reliques ont été
proposées par le croire de constantine
en par l'empereur beaudoin 2 de
constantinople contenait as à la
saint-louis puisqu'à l'époque il était
en difficulté financière est traversé de
grosses difficultés pour financer ses
campagnes militaires et donc il a décidé
de se séparer de la couronne d'épinés et
que l'europe france lui propose
d'acheter pour un prix absolument
extravagant à l'époque qui est de 135
mille livres juste pour vous donner un
rapport l'ensemble de la construction de
la sainte chapelle s'est élevé à 40
mille livres entre les 135 de
l'acquisition de la couronne d'épinés
louis 9 ne peut tolérer que ce symbole
de royauté de souffrance tombent entre
de mauvaises mains
concevant que sa mission sur terre doit
être marquée par la dignité et
l'humilité avec lui la couronne est
entre de bonnes mains
cette acquisition va apporter au roi
louis 9 non seulement l'objet de
dévotion de ce roi très pieux mais
également une assise politique beaucoup
plus forte puisque c'est la france qu'a
choisi le christ pour être détenteur de
cet insigne reliques de sa passion des
12 137 louis et blanches envoie un
émissaire mais il faudra encore deux ans
pour que la très sainte relique
rejoignent paris louis est allé au
devant de la couronne il entre avec elle
dans sa capitale portant la chasse qui
la protège en chemise pieds nus suivi
d'une cohorte de religieux et de
chevaliers eux aussi pieds nus la
procession qui s'ensuit se termine en
fête populaire
louis devant la couronne est en extase
on a beaucoup de mal aujourd'hui à se
figurer l'importance que revêtait les
reliques au xiiie siècle cet état un
objet de médiation en fait entre l'homme
et dieu
donc il y avait vraiment une importance
considérable et je vous donne une
histoire l'unef peut-être légende le roi
de france a été très très malade en
douce en 44 sec vraiment ils passeraient
qui ne survivrait pas à 7 à cette
maladie grave
la reine blanche de castille et ordonne
à ce moment-là collomb le place sur le
corps la couronne d'épinés le morceau de
la vraie croix et le roi guéri à
l'intérieur d'un état en pleine
restructuration
il continue à s'appuyer sur les valeurs
et les mentalités féodal et plus
concrètement sur un réseau d'alliances
le sommet de la pyramide féodal c'est le
roy le chef d'un état ou lien va salik
et appartenance au royaume doivent se
confondre
la principale menace planant sur cet
état monarchique en construction et la
présence d'un autre état monarchique
tout autant à la recherche d'un
équilibre le royaume d'angleterre dans
un monde féodal
il arrive bien souvent qu'en raison de
la complexité des réseaux familiaux des
engagements pris d'une part ne peuvent
être tenus à cause d'accords passés
d'autre part à la suite d'une de ces
crises en 241 henri iii se joint à une
révolte de seigneurs du sud-ouest
vassaux du roi de france tandis que
louis 9 des faits le roi d'angleterre à
taillebourg en 12 140 de la coalition
des vassaux va s'étendre jusqu'aux
languedoc via toulouse louis 9 1 6 m à
raison non seulement tous ses vassaux
mais aussi la résistance cathare qui se
concentre alors sur quelques châteaux
pyrénéen
alors saint louis pendant sa carrière de
roi va être confronté à la sphère des
cathares les cathares selon lui ce sont
des hérétiques pourquoi parce que ces
gens là refusent l'autorité du pape
or saint louis veut absolument marier le
pouvoir et l'église ils refusent
l'autorité du pape et ils veulent vivre
comme comme les vieux les vieux apôtres
d'autres froid c'est-à-dire dans
quasiment dans la misère dans la
sobriété et ils n'ont on sait que ils
sont installés du côté de monségur dans
le languedoc à toulouse etc
mais saint louis ne veut pas supporter
cette opposition au pape
et dieu sait qu'on va allumer un certain
nombre de bûcher pour en venir à bout
la prise du château de montségur en 12
144 après dix mois de siège se clôt par
la mise à mort sur le bûcher de 200
hérétiques cathares refusant d'abjurer
leur foi l'inquisition venait d'être
créé pour l'occasion
le royaume franc il était partagé entre
l'occitanie très romanisée et puis les
pays de langue deuil qui empruntait plus
haut à l'héritage des celtes et dans
cette guerre des cathares contre le roi
de france on s'aperçoit qu'il y a un
sentiment qu'on retrouvera plus tard
qu'ils aient le sentiment occitan oui 9
est un roi guerrier qui poursuit la
consolidation de son autorité à
l'intérieur d'un territoire en pleine
expansion et autour d'une union
chrétienne indéfectible en 12 144 tout
comme son père au retour d'une campagne
militaire menée dans le sud de la france
louis 9 épris de dysenterie ému par les
larmes de deux servantes qui le veille
et le croit agoniser il fait voeu de se
croiser et si dieu lui permet de se
rétablir et le rétablissement s'opère
[Musique]
alors oui ne fait était malade il est
souvent malade d'ailleurs il est de
petite santé et comme il est guéri il
promet de s'en aller à jérusalem pour
délivrer le tombeau de jésus-christ
[Musique]
un serment devant être tenu les
réactions sont très partagées la
croisade n'enthousiasme plus les foules
les dernières ont été des échecs pour
l'occident chrétien la relative
prospérité qui repoussent les famines
hors des limites du royaume de france a
contribué à l'essoufflement d'un idéal
celui de la croisade en orient et de la
reconquête de jérusalem
les foires de champagne sont un rendez
vous chaque année qu'il convient de ne
pas manquer pour rien au monde
pas même un pèlerinage à jérusalem
les mentalités évoluent on ne se
détournent plus aussi facilement des
biens terrestres louis 9 lui ne se
détourne pas aussi facilement d'un idéal
cependant il ne peut pas partir comme
cela une croisade nécessite un budget
des préparatifs militaires et un
ravitaillement suffisant emblée
vincelles et boit surtout louis ne veut
pas partir comme cela sans s'assurer
qu'il laisse un état en paix et en ordre
en 12 147 louis 9 organise une enquête
sur l'ensemble de son territoire pour
réformer les abus que ces agents comète
en son nom un royaume en ordre c'est un
royaume où règne la justice et blanches
en sera la garante pendant l'absence du
roi
[Musique]
il reste une dernière chose à faire pour
lui
depuis que paris abrite la sainte
couronne d'épinés un projet
architectural ambitieux prend forme dans
l'île de la cité
la sainte chapelle saint louis a acheté
la couronne d'épinés en 13 ans 12 139 et
deux ans plus tard en 241
il se porte acquéreur d'un deuxième lot
de reliques dont la pièce maîtresse de
ce deuxième lot était un morceau de la
vraie croix alors deux points sont
importants a précisé
d'une part le roi choisit de ne pas
mettre la couronne d'épinés les reliques
dans le trésor royal qui se trouve à san
initiale à la basilique saint denis qui
aurait été finalement sa place
normal non pas du tout rires choisi de
les placer au coeur de son palais de son
palais de la cité résidence des
capétiens
il se place ainsi sur le modèle de
charlemagne qui avait lui aussi créé sa
chapelle au sein de son palais et fait
adopter du coup au palais de la cité un
plan capécia avec le prolongement d'une
galerie provenant du palais lui
permettant d'arriver directement à la
sainte chapelle pour se prosterner
devant les reliques cette merveilleuse
j'appelle qu'on appellera la sainte
chapelle va être construite par un
architecte et rythmant ses pierres de
montreuil en quatre ou cinq années de
temps 1242 1246 elle va être inaugurée
si je puis dire en 1948 c'est à dire
l'année même de son départ en croisade
[Musique]
monument à la gloire de dieu tutti
équilibre les murs étant réduit à
l'extrême
la lumière y pénètre abondamment au
travers de verrières immense la sainte
chapelle est une prouesse technique dans
le cadre du développement de l'
architecture gothique lié lui même à
l'essor économique à la prospérité des
villes et au renforcement du pouvoir
capétiens centralisé sur paris la sainte
chapelle et la chapelle du palais royal
elle est consacrée le 26 avril 12 148 la
chapelle basse et la chapelle du palais
la chapelle donc réservé à toute la
domesticité du palais qui peut venir y
prier lorsqu elles le souhaitent
alors que la chapelle haute est réservé
aux souverains et au collège de chanoine
qui a été établi par le premier acte de
fondation 246 mais il ya également une
fonction symbolique dans cette structure
puisqu'il faut se mettre dans le dans
l'esprit du lieu du xiiie siècle à
l'époque il y a deux pôles
il ya un pôle spirituel qui est porté
par l'église et partout les
ecclésiastiques donc et puis le roi le
roi étant à la tête d'un peuple laïque
mais il faut toujours se rappeler qu'il
a reçu l'onction ce roi est donc cette
onction lui donne un pouvoir suprême à
prévoir de médiation avec dieu donc dans
cette architecture de chapelle basse on
va bien la position du roi entre son
peuple est dû au dessus de lui
le 12 juin louis quitte paris pour
partir en croisade
contrairement à ce qu'imaginent les
enlumineurs et les autres illustrateurs
de tout temps louis 9 ne part pas en
croisade vêtu comme un roi
mais comme un pèlerin humble et
pénitents
en intégrant la provence au domaine
royal louis 9 a ouvert au royaume de
france
les portes de la méditerranée
l'embarquement des croisés se faisant
généralement à marseille port situé à
l'intérieur du saint empire germanique
louis a fait construire de l'autre côté
du rhône le port des gants morte
alors au moment de partir en croisade
évidemment il se pose censément cette
question il me dit il me faut une base
sur la méditerranée pour pouvoir
embarquer vers la terre sainte et cette
base et bien ça ne peut pas être
marseille parce que marseille appartient
au roi de naples ça ne peut pas être
montpellier qui appartient au roi
d'aragon
donc ils trouvaient gourtay c'est là
qu'il va en effet décidé d'aménager est
morte comme comme rampe de lancement
vers la terre sainte
il y à là surtout une stratégie
économique afin de participer aux
échanges qui s'intensifie entre les port
italien de gênes et de venise et lorient
et bientôt l'extrême orient
mais est morte est aussi un port
militaire il 25 août 12 148 louis peut
prendre la mer d'un port français après
avoir réparti sur les 1800 navire les
huit mille chevaux l'armée s'embarque
2500 chevalier autant d'écuyer et de
vallet une quinzaine de milliers de
soldats à pied
pas loin de 25 mille hommes en tout tous
promis au salut éternel louis attend
beaucoup de cette croisade pense-t-il
qu'elle peut durer toujours est il que
sa femme l'accompagnait ainsi que ses
frères et leurs épouses la croisade est
une entreprise royal et dans une
monarchie encore féodal c'est donc une
entreprise familiale
il accoste à chypre en septembre lille
conquise par richard coeur de lion aux
191 et depuis une tête de pont pour les
armées en croisade
le premier objectif et l'egypte dont le
sultan très remuant s'attaque aux
possessions chrétienne la mer est trop
dangereuse en hiver louis et son armée
le past à chypre pourtant au printemps
12 149 enfin au large de l'egypte des
vents violents sépare en deux la flotte
royale
louis n'a plus que 700 chevalier avec
lui
cela n'empêche pas les croisés de
prendre la ville de damiette le 5 juin
12 149
mais la croisade va rapidement mal
tourné sur la route du caire les hommes
de louis 9 sont constamment harcelés par
les attaques des mamelouks qui composent
depuis des siècles une milice pour le
sultan d'égypte à l'origine ces
guerriers redoutables sont des esclaves
affranchis
au cours de cette septième croisade il
s'apprête à renverser le sultan mais une
autre menace plane sur l'armada
chrétienne le monde méditerranéen est
dangereux pour ses vents et ses vagues
mais il est aussi le monde des épidémies
un fléau s'abat sur les croisés le
scorbut la route du caire est encore
longue
tandis que nombre d'hommes sont atteints
et recrache la chair de leurs gencives
pourri avant de mourir oui 9 et ses
compagnons enchaîne les faits de
chevalerie notamment 9 février 12 150 à
l'occasion du siège de la citadelle de
mansourah où ils combattent et
l'emportent sans arc ni arbalète
mais à la masse et à l'épée la victoire
a un prix
un frère du roi a perdu la vie et l'art
mais usé par les épreuves et privées de
ravitaillement
les musulmans ont coupé la route qui
mène vers le
il il faut battre en retraite celle ci
prend fin le 6 avril 12 150 quand le roi
à une grande partie de ces sommes sont
faits prisonniers
c'est une tragédie pour un roi chrétien
que d'être aux mains des infidèles en
particulier quand votre femme donne
naissance à un nouveau fils prénommé
jean tristan afin de rappeler le
terrible événement auquel il sera à
jamais associé dès le départ ça
s'annonce pas trop mal d'ailleurs
puisque on arrive en egypte l'armée de
louis 9 parvient à s'emparer de damiette
et puis on marche en marche vers saint
jean d'âcre et c'est à ce moment là
qu'on est bloqué on devrait d'abord
essayer de marcher sur le caire parce
que la grande idée quand même aussi de
louis 9 c'était de faire de l'egypte une
colonie française
et on est arrêté à mansourah à mansourah
c'est là que d'ailleurs saint louis va
perdre son frère robert robert premier
d'artois et que lui-même après un
semblant de victoires va se faire
capturer par le dénommé bay bar le
mamelouk et on va devoir payer une
rançon pour la libération de saint louis
marguerite la jeune reine rester à
damiette avec une partie de l'armée
arrive à rassembler la rançon exigée par
le sultan en un temps record à moi le
réseau qui répondent aux besoins de la
croisade a bien fonctionné les banquiers
italiens ont avancé l'argent ayant des
assurances sur l' équilibre du trésor
royal
[Musique]
de saint jean d'âcre port chrétiens en
palestine à 150 km de jérusalem d'où il
doit prendre la mer pour retourner dans
son royaume comme il l'a promis à ses
geôliers louis 9 adresse une lettre au
peuple de france dans laquelle il
explique pourquoi la croisade continue
les musulmans n'ont pas tenu leurs
engagements non plus en ne libérant pas
les autres prisonniers louis se doit de
rester pour eux
[Musique]
quant à ces sujets la reine blanche est
une parfaite gouvernante
louis est aussi en attente de quelque
chose de bon les musulmans autorise le
pèlerinage à jérusalem
mais louis veut entrer dans une
jérusalem libre dans ce moyen orient la
situation est pourtant excessivement
complexe avec de nouveaux acteurs
repoussé ici par la terrible progression
mongol entre résistance tentative de
colonisation et d'évangélisation est
raide conquérant de moins en moins
fréquents les années s'écoulent jusqu'au
printemps 253
du royaume de france parvient alors une
nouvelle qui va plonger louis dans le
plus profond désespoir
sa mère la reine blanche de castille est
morte le 27 novembre de l'année
précédente
il n'était pas là et doit maintenant
préparer son retour laissant là les
mirages d'orient il va devoir rentrer en
france pourquoi parce que blanche de
galsi a rendu son âme aux dieux qu'elle
aimait tant et le royaume est donc sans
régence alors il faut qu'ils rentrent en
france et il abandonne donc cette
croisade la méditerranée qu'il traverse
de nouveau n'est plus la méditerranée de
la guerre sainte et des croisades
mais la méditerranée du commerce
transcontinental et des épices pourtant
lors de ce voyage le souvenir que
gardera la mémoire collective de saint
louis est en phase d'élaboration avancé
parti en croisade vêtu comme un pèlerin
il en revient aussi sobrement habillé et
reste ainsi tel impénitent
s'il n'a pas pu réussir à repousser les
sarrasins et les mongols du moins
peut-il suivre un autre idéal qu'il
avait laissée aux mains de blanche le
règne de la justice et de la paix au
royaume de france et dans tout l'extrême
occident chrétien
il convient que comme lui ces sujets
vivants pénitents
dès décembre 12 154 louis 9 promulgue la
grande ordonnance qui va réformer le
royaume
le but faire régner l'ordre moral
cette compilation de textes de loi prend
en compte le constat effectué lors de la
grande enquête de 12 147 les officiers
royaux doivent rendre la justice sans
discrimination sociale et sans accepté
deux pots de vin
[Musique]
pour être simple et précis on pourrait
dire que cette gorge cette grande
ordonnance de saint louis 7 c'est
quasiment comme une première
constitution que qui a été rédigé pour
pour l'administration du royaume ont il
ya tout dans cette grande ordonnance de
l'administration royale les impôts de la
nomination des baggy dans les régions
etc
le code de la justice tout est là je
crois que saint louis a réussi à créer
une constitution pour véritablement
gouverner la france comme un pays
moderne plus qu'une réforme
administrative
c'est une réforme profonde des
mentalités qui est le préalable au
projet de louis 9 des mentalités
perverti par l'essor économique dont
profite laïque et hommes d'église
alors que la grande ordonnance s'appuie
déjà sur des principes de la justice
moderne comme la présomption d'innocence
et l'intégrité
elle conserve de médiéval des lois qui
ressemblent davantage à des
prescriptions morales dans le but de
purifier le royaume
[Musique]
il est interdit de blasphémer les jeux
de hasard et d'argent sont proscrits les
prostituées sont bannis du lieu c'est à
dire des villes elles sont autorisées à
exercer hors des enceintes dans des
baraques en bois appelée board puis
bordel certains passages de la grande
ordonnance sans lui en place publique ce
dont louis a besoin c'est avant tout
l'adhésion de son peuple à son idéal
saint louis est un c'est une image
d'épinal et le roi qui rend la justice
sous un chêne et on sait si on veut
conforter cette image d'épinal que ce
chaîne aurait été planté à vincennes
c'est dans l'enceinte du château de
vincennes saint louis ça fait partie de
200 adoration pour dieu était très
proche des pauvres
et puis il voulait aussi que justice
soit rendue
alors pour cette justice qu'il va créer
véritablement un code de la justice
c'est à dire qu'on ne la dhr ont pu
n'importe comment mais il va y avoir des
enquêtes ont fait des enquêtes
on a droit à des défenseurs donc justice
est rendue de façon très savante
j'allais dire c'est vrai que saint louis
avait organisé des cours de justice où
on pouvait directement demander justice
au roi faut pas croire que c'était un
homme épris toujours d'équité absolue
quand il la rendait lui même c'était
parfois une justice exécutive et sauvage
s'ils ont blasphémé par exemple eh bien
on avait la langue coupée sur ordre du
roi ou la bouche
ébouillantez pour avoir blasphémé
d'autres hommes font le même constat que
le roi de france et celui ci va
d'ailleurs s'appuyer sur eux tout en
adoptant leur comportement et leur état
d'esprit
ces sommes vont participer avec louis 9
a bouleversé la société
ces sommes sont ceux qui rejoignent les
ordres mendiants
ils sont dominicains et franciscain pour
la plupart
saint louis qui porte bien son nom de st
on le sait était assez assez dit go
toujours un peu confit en dévotion
il priait assez régulièrement il
marchait pieds nus sur les pavés froid
pour ce faire pénitence et il aimait
s'entourer d'hommes qui savait prier et
c'est ainsi que il a il a aimé
s'entourer de deux moines de l'ordre de
saint dominique et et d'autres moines de
l'ordre de saint françois saint françois
d'assise qui est un un italien qui a
créé cet ordre religieux saint françois
d'assise un petit peu le premier écolo à
l'histoire parce que c'était être proche
de la nature pour être plus proche de
dieu ils se regroupent dans ces villes
qui prospère sans supprimer les
inégalités
il vise de charité pour développer la
culture du don de soi tournés vers leur
prochain ils mendient pour mieux servir
les pauvres par la parole
intermédiaire entre les hommes et dieux
ce sont des confesseurs des prédicateurs
et des médiateurs l'objectif de cette
médiation est de donner un sens à la vie
en suivant au plus près la parole de
l'évangile et moyens pour l'atteindre
son adoption d'un comportement des
tâches et les biens terrestres et
l'adhésion à des valeurs communes celle
du christ louis 9 y ajoute la
constitution d'une communauté à
l'intérieur d'un état monarchique il ya
le mouvement monarchique c'est à dire
les créations dhabi
d'ordre tout tous et ses monastères le
pays est couvert de monastères ce café
saint louis ce café louis 9 c'est que il
les a sécularisée en quelque sorte ces
moines c'est le dominicain c'est
franciscains il les a pu laisser
enfermer dans les couvents il a aimé
travailler avec eux dans la ville tous
les jours des villes les mendiants bat
la campagne grâce à l'appui du roi leur
monastère constitue bientôt un réseau
plus dense que les autres ordres
religieux soutenue par le roi ils vont
transformer un peuple de paysans en
véritable opinion publique opinion
publique qui avait pris conscience
d'elle-même
un dimanche à bouvines comme les
mendiants louis viii dévotement effet
manger les pauvres et dans les bois de
vincennes louis rend la justice aux
laissés-pour-compte à la veuve et à
l'orphelin saint louis a aussi s'est
penché sur la vie des pauvres en créant
on le sait d hôtel dieu que ce soit
pontoise que ce soit à l'hôtel dieu de
vernon que ce soit les 15 20 pour les
aveugles
c'est quelqu'un qui vaille est
véritablement sur ces sujets
c'est en cela que l'on peut parler de
moralisation de la vie politique et de
la vie quotidienne en même temps c'est
un véritable projet de gouvernement
rationnelle ou les évêques eux-mêmes
sont soumis à la grande ordonnance c'est
la constitution d'un état laïc mais avec
une idéologie médiévale de la réussite
de ce programme politique dépend le
salut d'un roi et de son peuple
en complément de ce pouvoir politique et
du pouvoir de l'église contrôlé par les
mendiants l'effervescence des villes
permet à d'autres pouvoir de s'exprimer
celui des universités notamment
l'université de paris est la référence
en matière de théologie la science qui
permet d'accéder au projet divin et donc
au salut c'est un fils de paysan robert
de sorbon qui après avoir lui-même gravi
les échelons de la hiérarchie sociale
grâce à des études supérieures fonde en
12 157 un collège pour étudiants en
théologie désargenté qui prend son nom
parmi les les prêtres l'aide que
saint-louis affectionné par dessus tout
il n'y en avait un qui s'appelait robert
robert de sorbon et robert de sorbon et
est un théologien théologien merveilleux
et qui a dit au roi un jour il faut
peut-être faire une grande grand collage
une grande école pour apprendre la
théologie pour apprendre les lettres et
saint louis lui donne le feu vert
et c'est ainsi que robert de sorbon va
créer ce qui est la première université
de l'histoire la sorbonne
après athènes après rome paris devient
la nouvelle capitale intellectuelle de
toute l'europe
la france elle même devient la référence
européenne des arts
m
l' architecture gothique et ses images
médiatiques assure le lien déjà
entretenu par les ordres mendiants entre
ce mouvement culturel qui prend forme et
le peuple de france
[Musique]
l'art et la culture ne sont pas les
seuls candidats pour assumer un
troisième pouvoir face aux politiques et
religieux une nouvelle classe sociale
fait déjà beaucoup parler d'elle la
bourgeoisie pendant le règne de du bon
roi saint louis
la bourgeoisie n'a pas à se plaindre
parce que elle est bien vue par par le
roi le roi qui l'organisent
véritablement les bourgeois sont
essentiellement des grands marchands des
marchands et il va où des artisans et il
va créer des corporations avec des
règlements pour ces gens là ils auront
le droit même dans une ville comme paris
a secret pour la nuit une milice pour la
sécurité chacun pouvant faire régner
l'ordre
donc les bourgeois sont extrêmement bien
considérer louis 9 fait preuve de la
même extrême rigueur dans le domaine
économique que dans le domaine de la
justice
l'efficacité du réseau financier
capétiens pendant la captivité de louis
témoigne de l' équilibre budgétaire du
royaume
ce réseau contrôler le pouvoir naissant
des bourgeois qui s'enrichissent grâce à
l'état qui ramène l'ordre en mettant un
terme aux incessants conflits d'intérêts
féodaux
la septième croisade a coûté cher mais
depuis le règne de la justice et de la
paix au royaume de france compense
largement ces dépenses utopique à
l'intérieur du royaume une loi
interdisant les duels judiciaire est
votée mais pas appliquer lui ne fait
plus moderne que son état naissant ne
peut l'être de retour des croisades
il reprend les choses en main les choses
qui avait laissé dans l'état parce que
blanche de castille était quand même
quelqu'un que tu es une bonne
gestionnaire mais enfin ils organisent
le royaume il va par exemple créer une
monnaie royale par exemple instaurer des
baggy avec des surveillants
naturellement des baillis pour toucher
les impôts parce que jusqu'à l'or ont
touché les impôts un petit peu en veux
tu en voilà on se faisait graisser la
patte et c'est donc il fait régner
l'ordre
financièrement en politique extérieure
louis 9 le juste l arbitre des conflits
entre les grands d'europe entre les
nations chrétiennes d'europe entre le
pape et l'empereur
oh
en 12 159 le traité de paris clôt ainsi
que l'on a appelé à posteriori la
première guerre de cent ans débuté au
milieu du 12e siècle avec le second
mariage d'aliénor d'aquitaine après la
trêve signée en douce 142 avec henri iii
salle oui le pacificateur accepte de
sceller l'entente entre les deux
royaumes par un traité officiel
il annonce la deuxième guerre de cent
ans il inclut l'obligation pour henri
iii de prêter l'hommage du vassallo
capétiens afin que l'angleterre puisse
conserver ses possessions en aquitaine
le traité de paris que saint-louis signe
c'est un un traité de paix qui signe un
petit peu dans la bonne humeur parce que
on est plus fâché avec l'angleterre et
il va redonner aux anglais en quelque
sorte la touraine la guyenne etc mais
leurs données avec une réserve en
quelque sorte parce que c'est c'est lui
le suzerain
ils peuvent ils vivent mais ce sont des
les vassaux tout simplement
en revanche il récupère case est
carrément la normandie comme étant un
territoire du royaume de france mais
tout se fait aimablement sans sang versé
le sang ce qui se trouve au coeur du
pouvoir de saint louis
c'est un rituel féodal et un idéal
médiévale mais également un projet
moderne imposé sur le long terme une
autorité qui centralise l'autorité
capétienne
que le coup est rude quand louis 9 père
son fils aîné éponyme en 12 160
mais louis 9 règne sur le plus grand
royaume d'europe
même face à l' empire il possède la plus
grande armée surtout à partir de 12 162
une série d'ordonnancés monétaire donne
progressivement aux ateliers royaux
quasi monopole de la frappe de la
monnaie ce qui permet à l'état de mieux
contrôler les prix et ce qui renforce
également la grande popularité de louis
9 après cinq siècles d'absence en 266
louis et le premier roi de france à
battre une monnaie d'or les qu il le
fait par prestige mais aussi avec la
volonté de concurrencer les autres
acteurs de l'économie méditerranéenne
venise gène byzance et l'islam
saint louis une fois de plus à une idée
de génie il s'est dit je vais frapper
une monnaie va qui sera la monnaie de la
france parce que on payait elle des
monnaies régionales assez régulièrement
alors on imagine les difficultés pour
les pour les conversions parce que ça
n'avait pas les mêmes valeurs la même
valeur si c'était en touraine
si c'était en picardie et c'est donc il
va créer une monnaie nationale
l'écu d'or et à partir de ce moment là
c'est véritablement encore un grand pas
vers le monde moderne et vers le progrès
dans sa volonté de maîtriser des
échanges et les flux financiers
louis édicte des lois afin de limiter
l'influencé des usuriers et en
particulier celle des non chrétiens pas
tant les étrangers que les juifs
en 12 169 afin de les empêcher de nuire
et l'imposent aux juifs de porter un
signe distinctif une rouelle jaune comme
l'or qui les pousse au péché capital de
l'avarice cette intolérance envers la
communauté juive s'appuie avant tout sur
des réseaux idéologique est pour l'heure
spirituel il a appliqué des mesures
discriminatoires à l'égard des juifs
façon curieuse d'ailleurs parce que
c'était les juifs convertis au
catholicisme qui lui demandait de
l'appliquer vis-à-vis de ceux qui
n'étaient pas converti c'est à dire des
des marques distinctives et puis
l'interdiction de l'usure et cetera en
étouffant le crédit juifs ces mesures
auront des conséquences économiques
catastrophiques au cours du 14e siècle
pire encore cette politique est une
étape fondamentale dans le processus
d'élaboration d'une idéologie antisémite
qui bouleversera l'europe bien des
siècles plus tard
où
louis est déraisonnable mais il vit une
passion le roi de france et le roi d'une
nation chrétienne
la fille aînée de l'église par le
baptême de clovis c'est aussi un
individu qui a des problèmes avec sa
conscience
la réforme de la chrétienté sous son
impulsion et celle des ordres mendiants
à transformer la notion de guerre sainte
cette guerre est en chacun de ces sujets
chacun par son comportement et son état
d'esprit peut gagner cette guerre et
servir ainsi la chrétienté tout en
permettant le salut de son âme pour les
hommes du xiiie siècle
le salut ne passe plus par la jérusalem
terrestre une seule exception louis 9
quand il décide de partir dans la
huitième et dernière croisade pense
qu'ils concernent
eh bien je crois qu'il n'a pas pris la
dimension de de l'état de la france et
de l'europe à ce moment là parce que il
y a moins de convictions religieuses
assurément il est moins suivi
il n'est pas ou ne l'accompagnent pas
avec avec enthousiasme avec fougue comme
dans les croisades précédentes parce que
en effet on finit par paraître un peu
saturé de ses campagnes de libération du
saint sépulcre et je crois qu'il est à
ce moment là un petit peu à côté de son
époque le 1er juillet 12 170 ils
s'embarquent pour la 8ème croisade
ce n'est pas tant une croisade de
conquête qu'une croisade expiation et de
conversion
la première étape est tunis afin de
convertir le sultan au christianisme
cette étape tout comme cette croisade
sera la dernière de nouveau une épidémie
de dysenterie ou de typhus s'abat sur
les croisés le fils de louis jean
tristan né en croisade en 12 150 meur en
croisade
à vingt ans d'intervalle le 3 août 12
170 son père succombe à son tour le 25
août 12 170 à carthage saint louis est
le roi de la dernière croisade la fin de
saint-louis coïncide avec la fin de l'
idéal liés à la croisade
à l'occasion de cette huitième croisade
on le sait il est à tunis
il est à tunis et il tombe malade alors
certains historiens nous disent que
c'est la peste d'autres nous disent que
c'est la dysenterie
en réalité ils étaient épuisés saint
louis c'est probablement à 10 entre il
était épuisé il avait perdu un oeil
il y avait d'ailleurs été très sensible
à tous et tout s'est croisé tous ces
soldats qui était malade et c'est pour
ça qu'il avait créée à paris des
hôpitaux notamment pour ceux qui avaient
perdu la vue les 15-20 c'est une
création de saint louis et alors il est
à tunis et il sait que sa dernière heure
est arrivée elle arrive en effet le 25
ou de 1270 sur un lit de cendres les
bras en croix
ouais un peu comme à l'image du
jésus-christ qui l'adoré temps eh bien
il rend son âme à dieu mais il était
véritablement épuisé malade il n'allait
plus ont dit qu'ils n'avaient plus
qu'une seule dans saint louis à la fin
de sa vie pourtant quand il meurt louis
9 n'est pas encore saint louis
d'éviscérer embaumée son corps est
bouillie avec un vin aromatisé pendant
de longues heures afin de séparer les
eaux de la chaire tandis qu'une partie
des restes est enterré en tunisie
les ossements qui sont autant de
reliques sont rapatriés par philippe le
hardi à la basilique saint denis le 22
mai 271 leroy s'affirment plus roi que
jamais dans la mort on n'enterre pas un
roi n'importe où c'est un véritable
service d'ordre qui permet le passage de
la dépouille
toutes les petites gens veulent rendre
un dernier hommage à celui qui a servi
la justice c'est avant tout à cet appel
celui de cette opinion publique en
formation que répond la procédure de
canonisation
on ramène sa dépouille enfin c'est au
parce que évidemment il y avait un bout
de route quand même depuis tunis jusqu'à
saint denis
alors on va faire vous dire son cadavre
les chairs les entrailles etc vont
rester vont être déposées dans un
monastère de sicile et les eaux vont
être apportées à saint denis
on va s'apercevoir que quiconque allait
se recueillir sur sa tombe s'il était
boiteux par exemple risque est de
pouvoir traiter comme un chat maigre que
les aveugles retrouvait la vue l'us
saint louis louis 9 faisait des miracles
alors ça vient à l'oreille de rome et en
1217 le pape boniface décide en effet de
canoniser saint-louis longtemps ralenti
pour des raisons politiques
cette procédure fini par se conclure par
un procès de canonisation
puis le 11 août 12 197 louis neuf
devient le premier roi de france
sanctifié solennellement par le pape y
restera le seul en 13 106 les reliques
de saint louis sont transférés à la
sainte chapelle
trois ans plus tard le chroniqueur jean
de joinville compagnons de saint louis
lors de la septième croisade témoin au
procès de canonisation remet à louis 10
une biographie saint louis n'est pas
qu'une construction de l'imaginaire
populaire
mais le chef d'un état qui se modernise
un chef d'état a accroché un idéal qui
n'est que nostalgie pour les plus
lucides
après avoir parachevé l'oeuvre de
philippe auguste en s'installant au
sommet de la pyramide féodal saint louis
a donné un tout autre sens à cette
logique hiérarchique en rendant la
justice aux plus humbles et en assurant
la paix st louis a permis de mettre un
terme à la féodalité le pouvoir ne se
trouve plus émietté mais centralisées à
paris
une centralisation du pouvoir qui va
progressivement pendant de longs siècles
mettre à mal toutes les coutumes et tous
les usages médiévaux le règne de louis 9
est une véritable station de
correspondance entre deux systèmes
politiques et deux modes de pensée bien
avant françois 1er face au dynamisme
économique
saint louis s'est adapté politiquement
mais aussi culturellement sage et
vertueux il apparaîtra comme un modèle
de monarque éclairé au xviiie siècle
pour les lumières
il est avant tout un roi qui a marqué la
conscience populaire un don quichotte
qui avait fait ses preuves
le 19 mai 1940 à lui à notre dame de
paris
une cérémonie religieuse pour protéger
paris de l'avancée allemande on exhibe
alors la sainte couronne d'épinés lors
d'une procession comme cela se fait
encore aujourd'hui le premier vendredi
de chaque mois